[Applaudissements]
ont déclamé les uns après les autres
leur discours argumenté et structurés en
créole devant une centaine de personnes
et les lycéens ne manquent pas
d'arguments pour parler de leur identité
[Musique]
des paroles qui touchent directement le
public certains ont même envie de signer
on garde le créole j'espère que sera le
reconnu le parler France en classe mais
transmet à mes enfants le créole
beaucoup j'ai beaucoup aimé les
prestations c'était bien cherché bien
expliqué c'est super et tout ben ma
copine elle a passé en 4e
parce que ben elle a assuré elle a bien
passé tout était super en tout cas tu as
une bonne initiative d'organiser un
concours comme ça c'est pas forcément
parce que cause créole que ben forcément
bien par causé ou bien pas travailler
dans un bureau plus importantes quoi le
concours est organisé par le Conseil de
la culture de l'éducation et de
l'environnement et vise à prouver qu'il
est possible de bien s'exprimer dans
notre langue causée l'événement a
suscité de l'intérêt ils étaient 200
participants au départ bonne lycéen
impliquée dans les affaires the de
l'envie de cause des autres langues vous
avez envie de mettre à lire en l'air de
l'envie de prendre soin on a envie de
littéraliser politisation
il évolue tout ça peut-être que les
Francis un peu trop parfois mais que
c'est un langue qui bouge et qui cause
avec un peu de mots français avec des
mots anglais sous vés mais elle est
comme ça donc à partir de là où on peut
maman il a bien les baises c'est
finalement Ornella qui convainc le plus
le jury la lycéenne remporte ce premier
cosarlor cristalline et Célia sont aussi
sur le podium c'est fier de l'attaque de
la classe fier du texte fier de mon
moment de mon papa que la laisse à ma
fait ça j'espère que ce sera pas la
dernière fois que mes frères Concorde
d'éloquence mon texte c'est un truc que
tu dominiconier les histoires des
oreilles donc il m'a voulu partager ça
et voilà il est très content d'avoir
représenté ce que ma maman l'a appris à
moi depuis toute petite donc c'est sûr
tout ça ma victoire aujourd'hui
elle a toujours appris à moins que la
beauté d'un visage les Vrillac comparer
la richesse d'un cœur
rendez-vous et d'ores et déjà pris
l'année prochaine pour tous les amoureux
du créole l'édition promet d'être encore
plus riche